sultan al-masri was wounded in the first
minutes of this conflict
his pain has barely begun he spent five
days in a coma
and has now had four major operations on
life-changing injuries
but sultan isn't yet fully awake to how
much his world has changed
his family is keeping it from him
i was on the street we were hit with a
rocket myself and my cousin
we fell down sultan hasn't been told
that the blast also killed his brother
ahmed
and sultan's only child 15 month old
yazan
family members say they could see the
rocket flying directly towards them
low to the ground out here in the street
is where sultan
sustained his injuries this is the
precise place where that
israeli munition came in and exploded he
was among
a group of his extended family who were
playing here putting hay
in sacks and in an instant eight of them
lost their lives
seven of them children that was among
the first israeli strikes of the
conflict
this was among the last the family home
hit on thursday night
hours before the ceasefire took effect
meters from that impact
sultan's cousin sits with his father
muhammad lost an eye in the same attack
but everyone is most worried about
sultan
he's emotional he loves his son too much
and his brothers
his soul is with them we are afraid that
something might happen to him his
injuries are so serious
gaza's main hospital is full of personal
tragedies and exhausted staff
too many people couldn't come to the
hospital during the war normal injuries
diabetes sufferers those with high blood
pressure they couldn't reach the
hospital and the ambulances couldn't
reach them because of the damaged roads
medical equipment and fuel are just
starting to get in but the hospitals
need regular electricity and clean water
infrastructure that needs rebuilding
throughout the strip the destruction of
this most recent war is creating grim
new landmarks to go alongside those of
the previous war and the one before that
so much never rebuilt everybody is
saying it should not be business as
usual you know the definition of
insanity
doing the same things with the same bad
results we don't want to go down there
again
how we manage that it comes down to
political will
by everybody to recognize that we just
can't continue this way
for years this has been the way in gaza
life getting steadily more difficult
more hopeless promises of change have
come before and gone before
gaza's people long accustomed to making
what they can of things
among the ruins harry fawcett al jazeera
northern gaza